you've had such a good career and you
are so well known but you get mistaken
for the actress jessica chastain yeah
these days and i'm just curious and and
in fact
um we have a still i believe a picture
of jessica saying but do people come up
to you on the street and say hey i love
you jessica chastain you have to oh yeah
all the time only only when i'm looking
presentable and i have makeup on when i
look like myself nobody thinks i look
like jessica chastain right yeah we a
fan posted a video online
about this phenomenon and uh we'll we'll
talk about it in a second it's really
funny but the
the uh let's show it first this is a fan
who made this completely on their own
put it online and it went viral take a
look everywhere i go i hear them
whispering wondering isn't that her yes
that's jessica chastain we were both in
the help yes but who did i play you
don't know it's a blur thanks to jessica
chester
all the critics once considered me a
highlight is this payback for the role i
stole in twilight
i am not
jessica chastain
[Music]
[Applause]
here's what's weird someone
someone made this on their own put it up
when it goes viral and many people think
that you made it that that's you singing
it's not just many people it's my
parents
and i cannot convince them otherwise
right they so yeah this video went up
like a couple days ago and one of my
friends sent it to me and they said oh
it would be fun if you did like a dub
smash where you know you you like lip
sync to the to the lyrics and so i did
that and then jess posted that on her
social media right and so you know
there's something like inherently meta
about all of that so i understand the
confusion because i look like her and
i'm on her social media account saying
that i'm not jessica chastain that's
very confusing right and so i i called
my parents they they saw the video
someone sent them the video and they
emailed me and they said it's genius
that video is genius when did you have
the time to do it i it's exactly your
sense of humor and my dad emails me and
he says um i showed it to hanks and he
thinks you are brilliant
showed it to tom hanks tom hanks that's
great so then i so then i called them
and i was just like
allow me to explain
i tried to articulate this to them on
email they just they didn't get it and
then you know after that was when i got
the hank's um email and i said this is
not um this is not my doing
i did do the the dub smash you
understand what the word dub means
because they also thought it was my
voice they thought that was your voice
i know it's amazing too your dad is one
of the finest filmmakers in the world
but he's still a dad and doesn't get it
he doesn't you know
it'd be like i sent it to my parents and
then and then he said and i was like
well you know and he was like oh yeah
hanks thought your voice was so
beautiful i was like well you you need
to tell him that it's not my voice he
said well i like him thinking that it
was your fault yeah see that's what
we're different
if someone mistakenly showed tom hanks
something and he said wow conan
o'brien's brilliant and it wasn't mine
i'd be i'd say thank you